Today, unlike in the past, people are blessed with everything.Did that make
you stronger in the true sense of the word
?When we were young, it was a time of great
war.
Is
it better to
disguise yourself in the
Showa era?
You can't fight with people like that.
If you're the master who actually fought
Otsuki, you should know what I'm saying.
Dad, give me a command No, that old man said it was milk.
There are people like that out there.The reason why
Sora and the others were created is that we still need March's cooperation to perfect the new technology.
If they will fight for us,
they will definitely protect us, so
even taxes are fine.